begin with bad weather we warned you
about it yesterday and in fact it came
to pass at least 17 confirmed tornadoes
in texas and oklahoma this is what it
looked like inside one of those storms
from a tv camera in round rock texas you
can see just some of the destruction
left in the wake of that twister in
elgin southeast of there the driver of a
red pickup truck barely survived when
high winds flipped the truck onto its
side
let's go to chris van cleave who is in
hard hit jacksboro texas that's about 60
miles northwest of fort worth chris
these pictures are really something good
morning
tony amazing survivor story here this
was the gymnasium of the elementary
school and city leaders got about a half
hour heads up that they could be in the
bullseye of the tornado that gave enough
time for staff here to get the 500
students parents and teachers into a
safe area just as the tornado struck
[Music]
caught inside the powerful line of
tornadoes tearing through texas and
oklahoma monday watch as this driver and
elgin somehow maintains control cheating
death and driving off
the storm brought wind pounding rain and
hail it's on the ground
at least dozens of homes are believed
damaged or destroyed
a twister ravaged the small texas town
of jacksboro just a school was about to
let out parents like ali vanderkay
waiting to pick up kids were rushed
inside moments before the building took
a direct hit insulation and the roof was
blowing over us and it was loud and
crazy and chaotic both the elementary
school and the nearby high school
experienced heavy damage just feet from
where hundreds of students teachers and
parents were hiding from the storm came
out and i saw like the trees like
uprooted like how that's powerful the
roof of the gym ripped off walls
collapsed while cars in the parking lot
tossed and flipped upside down your
family is here you're holding the bumper
of your car in your hand
what goes through your mind i'm just
glad they're safe despite the damage no
one at either school was hurt but the
tornado left a two-mile path of
destruction the city estimates 60 to 80
homes in this community of about 4 400
were damaged it's pretty much a miracle
that we don't have any major injuries
for for the damage that's been sustained
out there
and now just on the other side of all of
this debris the wall that's standing
that is where hundreds of people took
shelter now we just spoke with the
city's police chief overnight they
received no additional reports of
injuries
and this is remarkable no deaths across
this hard-hit town but there is a huge
mess here to clean up and an awful lot
to rebuild nate
chris thank you